ce corridor d'être ici je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai accepté de venir
vous faites j'ai passé toute la semaine
à me demander
qu'est ce que je voulais faire là
du coup conférence sur l'identité on
t'aime c'est la construction de soi à
l'ère du digital
peut-être vous pouvez m'aider
pourquoi vous avez acheté votre place
ça y est ce que vous faites là
pourquoi vous me regardez
quand il veut faire un truc spécial
bon
jeu c'est d'y aller étape par étape tout
d'abord l'identité qu'est ce que c'est
on est plein de personnes ici qui nous
ont à chaque fois posé une version
différente de l'identité
peut-être que l'identité c'est parce que
c'est la provocation je me suis posé en
fait j hockey déjà on va partir sur
l'identité identité sais qui je suis
d'accord mais je suis qui ce que je suis
est liée aux bains et lyon c'est mon
prénom en fait c'est à dire que c'est un
son qu'on m'assigne à ma naissance dont
les gens sortent pour me désigner mais
c'est pas moi au final
alors je dis
ce que vous voyez c'est mon corps
mais j'ai pas mon corps la preuve c'est
que c'est mon corps ce calcul qui
m'appartient mais c'est pas moi
j'appartiens plusieurs groupes je suis
un homme je suis je suis métis ont fait
parce que mon père est bien l'amérique
du sud que j'ai l'air d'être un homme
blanc je m'excuse de cette catégorie
parce qu'apparemment ce n'est pas plus
heureux pas toujours bien vu
je fais des études
est-ce que ça mes études qu'il définit
c'est ce que je suis un ex étudiant ce
que je suis youtuber parce que je suis
peu de caster
en fait j'ai pas qui je suis
tout ce que je sais en fait
c'est que je suis quelque chose
qui a conscience d'être quelque chose
sans savoir quoi est ce que je pense je
pas sûr est ce que tu penses c'est que
c'est pareil pour vous
peut-être je me trompe en fait
il ya des pnj dans la salle
est ce que quelqu'un sait qu'il suffit
qu'il ait
enfin tu appartiens plusieurs catégories
qu'il en serait de voir encore une femme
mais au fond je sais pas si vous voyez
ce que je vous dit en fait je sais pas
si on parle de la même chose c'est
interactif en fait hein donc vous pouvez
me répondre parce qu'il va je suis en
improvisation le procès qui vient de
finir 2e est ce que quelqu'un
c'est au fond au delà de toutes les
catégories auxquelles on peut appartenir
qui il est est-ce que vous avez tous
l'impression d'être conscient levez la
main ceux qui sont pas conscients
ceux qui sont pas conscients que c'est
un piège en fait parce que vous avez
l'âme en fait c'est que voilà
ok donc vous êtes tous conscients
en fait on est un peu dans la merde
parce que
excusez moi parce que je pense pas que
ce soit par simple curiosité que j'ai
envie de savoir qui je suis
j'ai envie de
[Musique]
comprendre la nature de mon rapport avec
ce monde pour savoir quoi faire au final
parce que si je sais pas qui je suis si
je comprends pas le monde dans lequel je
suis
c'est parce que je pas quoi faire en
fait de belles journées en fait comment
je vais diriger les actions
comment je fais pour savoir qui je suis
ce que je peux me dire en fait c'est que
si vous êtes tous en train
fondamentalement de vivre la même
expérience que moi c'est impossible
d'être plus des personnes conscientes
qu'il savait pas vos fonds qui elles
sont moi je peux vous observez en fait
parce que si je t'observe toi toi toi
toi toi toi toi et toi
que je vous écoute aussi
je vais pouvoir obtenir un peu plus
d'informations sur qui est ce que je
suis moi
qui ai
donc en fait je vais vous espionnez
je vous espionner et je pense que c'est
ce qu'on fait tous en fait on s'observe
constamment on s'observe constamment
pour en fait
pouvoir mettre le doigt sur la nature de
l'expérience humaine c'est ce qui nous
intéresse au fond je pense que c'est
pour ça que vous êtes la tête je me
trompe ce qu'il y en a qui pensent que
je me trompe complètement un nouveau
site interactif
non vous sentez un truc là ou pas ok ok
ok
et que trois personnes qui ont guy
nantel
puisque il
exactement à travers ce que les autres
disent de moi mais à travers ce que les
autres disent d'eux à travers ce que les
autres disent de leur expérience de ce
qu'ils vivent à travers leur histoire
aujourd'hui on a entendu des gens parler
et à chaque fois on essaye d'extraire de
l'information sur ces histoires pour au
final se comprendre c'est ce que je
pense qu'on fait
parce que du coup comme je les dis si je
vous observe
si je vous observe je peux me comprendre
un peu mieux si maintenant
j'écoute quelqu'un parler et qui au
final dans ce qu'il dit je retrouve une
idée que j'avais déjà entendus dans ce
qu'une autre personne m'avait raconté
c'est à dire que j'entends l'histoire
d'un speaker je veux dire tiens c'est
marrant il ya un petit truc en fait ça
je le retrouve aussi chez lui chez lui
chez cette personne est cette personne
là
cette idée
elle va m'intéresser
parce que je vais le dire que s'il ya
plusieurs autres personnes conscientes
qui vivent ce truc c'est que ça doit
être quelque chose d'intéressant donc je
vais creuser un petit peu
la raison pour laquelle cette idée je
vais la retrouver chez plusieurs
personnes c'est parce qu'au final je
pars de l'idée que vous êtes tous ont
fait eux aussi perdu comment vous savez
pas qui vous êtes si je me contentais
juste d'observer toi ou de t'ecouter toi
tu me communiquer une idée au final ça
ne suffirait pas pour moi ce que je veux
dire il faut que je la trouve chez plein
de gens je trouve une idée chez plein de
gens bas elle m'intéresse je commence à
y réfléchir j'ai réfléchi donc j'essaie
de la comprendre dans son abstraction
mais ça suffit pas faut que je vais
soumettre au test du réel faut que je la
teste donc cette idée je vais l'incarner
je vais 7 vivre
je laissais de
de laisser cette idée se manifester à
travers moi et je vois ce qui se passe
ce qui va m'intéresser
c'est de voir si au final cette idée
elle permettrait pas de donner
un petit peu plus de sens
à mon expérience sur terre
ce qui va aussi l'intéressé c'est de
voir la réaction des gens puisque une
fois de plus c'est pareil je pense
donc votre votre feedback il est
important
un autre feedback qui est important en
fait je me suis en train d'y penser
maman m'a peut-être c'est plus
intéressant de revenir après dessus
c'est le feedback que le feedback de la
culture
je pense que j'en parle un peu un peu
plus tard j'aimerais juste aller à la
fin du raisonnement donc j'observe une
idée j'ai réfléchi je la teste
je reçois un feedback je réfléchis aux
feedbacks parce qu'au final c'est pas
parce qu'on me dit que l'idéal est
éclatée que les forcément éclaté savoir
qu'on mette les choses en question
et si après avoir réfléchi au feedback
je vois en plus de ça que cette idée
donne plus de sens à ma vie
belge avait décidé de la garder en fait
ou pas au final si elle a pas mal de
plus de 100 somalie
et en fait c'est je pense
comme ça que je me construis
j'observe des gens
et je les imitent et le regard ça
fonctionne je pense que c'est ça la
construction de soi donc dans la quête
de mon identité
je me construis
je vais devoir faire hors sujet complet
je sais pas si vous m'avez suivi un
petit peu
ah oui 7digital
du coup au digital j'ai des slides
ouais c'est pas ça
il faut que j'aille dans l'autre sens à
ce parce que je tenais à vous faire
voilà ça c'est parce que en fait j'ai
passé toute la semaine dernière à tous
les jours préparer un texte et tous les
matins effacer mon texte parce que je me
disais que je vais pas vous parler de ce
truc
et qui au final ben j'ai décidé de vous
présenter un dessin que j'avais fait
c'est joli ou pas ouais merci pour votre
fille de 13 ans
donc
je pense qu'on pourra vraiment sur ce
dessin à la fin du talk construction de
soi est déjà pourquoi les invités
pourquoi je suis là en fait pas
comment tu m'as connu
donc je suis ici parce que je fais des
vidéos sur youtube
ok
peut-être c est ce que je dis dans ces
vidéos qui intéresse
ok
au final c'est pas forcément à cause de
moi c'est à cause des idées que je
transmets
je pense que si j'ai fait ces vidéos
parce que du coup je me posais toujours
cette question tu auras fait je me suis
fait un peu aspiré dans la question de
qui est ce que j'étais et pourquoi je
suis municipaux relais et je pense que
si on va inviter c'est parce que ben
comme je l'expliqué tout à l'heure j'ai
entendu des idées
j'y ai réfléchi je les ai observés chez
des gens j'ai vu des gens les incarner
je décide est détesté j'ai vu la
réaction j'ai réfléchi mais je ne suis
pas arrêté là parce que j'ai ensuite
décidé de les exprimer j'ai décidé de
leur prêter ma bouche
pour lui faire partir plus loin
en fait ça a plu aux gens
ça va parler à des gens des gens qui me
coûtait ses idées ils sont durs mais ça
a l'air pas mal et du coup nous
continuons à regarder et ce qui est fou
c'est que
c'est quelque chose que j'ai
l'impression qu'on a toujours fait
travers les différentes formes d'art que
ce soit le cinéma
que ce soit la littérature sur le
théâtre
et aujourd'hui on fait à travers des
technologies du coup comme youtube
instagram fait des tic toc
est ce qu'on recherche quand on le fait
c'est le feedback des autres finales
toujours dans cette même quête de la
construction de ce soir
là j'ai un blanc
seing vrai blanc dix mois
et 3 millions
parce que tu trouves carte de canal
très intéressant si tu m'as sauvé tu
m'as sauvé de montblanc
du coup pour répondre à la question je
sais pas si vous avez entendu elle me
demandait s'il y avait un décalage
parfois entre mon identité moi en tant
que personne physique ou peut-être pas
physique en tant qu autre chose et
l'identité que les gens pouvaient
découvrir sur les réseaux sociaux alors
je pense que forcément il ya un décalage
je pense que la seule manière de ne pas
avoir un décalage ce serait d'avoir une
caméra qui filme en en permanence
forcément je sélectionne ce que je
décide de montrer sur les réseaux
donc les gens ce qu'ils voient de moi
c'est qu'une petite partie de ce que je
décide de manifester et d'exprimer
publiquement
mais au final c'est pas moi est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai beaucoup de
peine à préparer stock c'est parce que
j'avais envie justement de montrer le
décalage entre ces deux choses mais dès
que j'ai commencé j'ai commencé j'ai dû
commencer par pour me demander qu'est ce
qu'elle était le graal c'est intéressant
parce que je pense que la réponse que
j'ai pu trouver c'est que je suis
simplement quelque chose
qui doit se construire en fait qui doit
se construire indépendamment de
indépendamment des difficultés de la vie
parce que j'en ai rendu visite et de
malice pas parce que je fais des trucs
sur instagram et où j'en ai pas on en a
tous peu importe
peu importe d'où on vient puis importe
qui on est on souffre des fournées
triste défonçant seules défendues tu
fonces des tests
est ce que j'ai trouvé beau dans
certains discours c'est de vendre à quel
point certains d'entre vous enfin
certains des speakers ont transcendé
cette souffrance il avait quelque chose
qui les à souffrir ils ont essayé de le
transcender pour venir l'exprimer sur
scène ils en ont fait leur force sa
chaussette revend
donc nos félicitations j'ai aussi
beaucoup aimé le litre des choses sur
l'année là je trouvais que c'était pas
mal
je trouve cool que cette citation de
georges st-pierre qui expliquait que
c'était plus qu'un sport que ça allait
au delà d'un sport que c'était quelque
chose d'autre je suis très d'accord avec
ça en fait parce que je pense qu'il ya à
travers le mma je suis votre thème genre
pour pékin je pense qu'à travers le mma
ce que les gens voient c'est le mode de
résolution finale d'un conflit on voit
souvent des joueurs de foot quand ils
sont frustrés ils viennent ils sont des
dettes comptait-il ont vite se bat par
exemple plusieurs sports on a envie de
se battre parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
résout un conflit
de manière utile c'est à dire c'est la
bonne manière pas tapé c'est pas bien
c'est mieux surtout de faire autrement
mais c'est ça qui passionne et qui
fascine dans la n va mais je pense très
très intéressant bref nintendo s 4
minutes fallait que je continue d'accord
dix mois avec plaisir
endroit et
qui semble la zone de confort
ou alors
la chance que mes expériences quoi qu'il
en soit merci beaucoup pour ta question
merci beaucoup les expériences qu'il en
soit je les garde avec moi j'avance et
je me construis par dessus mais
constamment sur l'évolution c'est pour
ça que je suis pas très fan de l'idée
selon laquelle mon identité au final
c'est le résultat de mes expériences
constate mes expériences nous
définissent parce que si mes expériences
yann me définisse bien
ça veut dire que la semaine passée que
j'étais quelqu'un de différent je
n'avais pas expérimenter les choses que
j'ai expérimenté toute cette semaine bah
ouais j'étais quelqu'un différence même
passer quelqu'un différents le mois
d'avant et au final c'est pas
l'impression que j'ai au fond de moi
j'ai l'impression que même quand j'avais
13 ans que je vivais des choses c'est
toujours moi qui les lie vas tu restes
et inversement avec moins d'expérience
peut être mais c'était toujours moi donc
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une espèce de
de base à partir de laquelle il ya
plusieurs expériences qui se détache qui
se rattachent parfois on accepte de
déconstruire des petits bouts de cette
expérience tu vois on dit ok mais cette
idée en fait que j'ai décidé de garder
au final il me plaît plus parce que le
fonctionne pas je peux te donner un
exemple quand j'étais petit quand
j'avais 10 ans et que je pensais au
futur je pensais que ça allait toute
façon à trouver génial que tout allait
bien se passer avec le futur ça vous
forcément mer que le présent et en
grandissant j'ai forcément dû me rendre
compte que c'est pas nécessairement vrai
que parfois fallu faire des sacrifices
parfois fallait travailler un petit peu
si on voulait construire son avenir mais
j'ai gardé cette idée en fait j'étais
attaché parce qu'elle me permettait de
ne pas avoir à travailler pas avoir à
fournir d'efforts à l'école et là je te
parle d'eux quand je suis arrivé au
lycée quand j'ai eu 18 19 ans je
continue à lui seul en structure je
continuais juste à
je fumais dépêche
je faisais la fête je m'amusais avec les
gens est à la fois je me permettait de
rêver et de
d'avoir si tu oses en gaule plus grande
je voulais construire mais je lâchais
pas cette idée est la raison pour
laquelle je ne lâchais pas c'est parce
qu'elle me permettait d'atténuer
l'anxiété que je considère votre pardon
vis-à-vis du futur la main dans le futur
en fait ça va être mieux et si c'est si
ça pas été mieux jusqu'à maintenant
c'est que ce sera mieux plus tard et un
jour en fait j'étais forcé de me dire
écoutez les hoba
tu sais très bien que tu es en train de
te mentir à thomas
et la raison est là du coup je pouvoir
faire peut-être faire un petit lien avec
le digital la manière dont j'ai pu le
faire ça a été de découvrir à travers
des vidéos youtube des nouvelles idées
des idées comme ceux dans lesquels il
fallait travailler sans lesquelles il
fallait construire mon avenir et c'est
un choix il ya des stickers qui partage
les idées comme ça donc au début je les
entendais ses idées j'avais pas envie de
les accepter
et parce que si je les acceptais s'est
impliqué de d'accepter que jusqu'ici je
vivais dans le mensonge à moi même j'ai
pas envie de le faire je n'ai pas envie
de lâcher cette partie noire
puis un jour j'ai accepté de le faire
j'ai testé l'idée j'ai regardé ce qui se
passait et j'ai vu que c'était positif
pour harcèlement tout le monde
et du coup tu as question c'était si
je les garde effectivement je les garde
parce que même une idée qui n'a pas
fonctionné au moins tu sais qu'elle n'a
pas fonctionné du coup tu peux passer à
autre chose et c'est de tester un
nouveau truc et quand tu vois que ton
idée allait bien pour toi pendant
je pense que mes études de droit elle
m'a appris la rigueur elles m'ont appris
à me poser et à travailler non peut-être
appris à
penser c'est une expérience qui était
nécessaire tu vois pour me construire je
pense pas que je fais du mal autour de
moi le faisant
je pensais déjà pas mal
et j'ai appris pas mal de trucs
intéressants donc
j'ai pas mes lunettes
à 10 min 17 bon
on m'a dit que
vous pouvez continuer à parler je sais
pas si vous voulez m'aider à comprendre
qui je vois que vous avez des questions
mais apparemment la caméra elle va se
couper on nous reparle après ok donc
après ou alors au pire on parle juste
donc merci de m'avoir écouté j'espère
que ça vous aura plu je n'aurais
peut-être
tu vas me le dire d'accord